Almost daily, the news is full of stories of high school and college seniors missing out on their graduation ceremonies and of people being unable to see and touch their loved ones who are suffering from COVID-19. Some of the more heartbreaking accounts feature families having to bury loved ones without funerals or formal mourning. The coronavirus is keeping us from experiencing some of the deepest and most meaningful rituals of our lives. What is this doing to us psychologically? How important are rituals to our mental health and well-being? What new rituals might we be creating? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Michael I. Norton, a professor of business administration at the Harvard Business School, and a member of Harvard's Behavioral Insights Group. His research covers a gamut of fascinating topics from money to daydreaming, from greed to deception.
几乎每天，新闻里都充斥着高中和大学毕业生错过毕业典礼的故事，以及人们无法探望和触摸因新冠肺炎而痛苦的挚友亲朋。一些更令人心碎的故事包括家庭在没有葬礼或正式哀悼的情况下埋葬亲人。冠状病毒使我们无法体验生活中一些最深刻、最有意义的仪式。这在心理上对我们造成了什么影响？仪式对我们的心理健康和幸福有多重要？我们可能会创造什么新仪式？欢迎收看《心理学演讲》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是哈佛商学院商业管理教授、哈佛行为洞察小组成员迈克尔·I·诺顿博士。他的研究涵盖了从金钱到白日梦、从贪婪到欺骗等一系列迷人的主题。
But I asked him here today to talk primarily about rituals in light of the COVID-19 pandemic. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Norton. Thank you so much for inviting me. I think we probably all have an idea of what rituals are, but it always helps to have a common language. Is it, for example, a ritual to take a coffee break every day at 1015, or is that just a habit? What are the differences between rituals and habits? Could you define for our listeners what constitutes a ritual? There certainly lie on a continuum.
但我今天请他来主要是为了讨论鉴于新冠肺炎疫情的仪式。欢迎来到心理学演讲，诺顿博士。非常感谢邀请我。我想我们大概都知道仪式是什么，但拥有共同的语言总是很有帮助的。例如，每天10点15分喝杯咖啡算不算仪式，还是仅仅是一个习惯？仪式和习惯有什么区别？你能为我们的听众定义一下什么是仪式吗？它们当然存在于一个连续体上。
So there are a lot of habits that have some ritualistic elements. And there are a lot of rituals that, of course, look a lot like habits. So it's hard to differentiate them into pure, that's purely a habit and that's purely a ritual. But one way to think about that continuum is, if I ask you in the morning, do you first brush your teeth and then take a shower? or do you first take a shower and then brush your teeth? Crazily, when I asked that question, in countries all over the world, actually, about 50% of people do it one way and 50% of people do it the other way. So they have this thing they do every morning,
所以有许多习惯包含一些仪式性的元素。也有许多仪式，当然，看起来很像习惯。因此，很难将它们区分为纯粹是习惯和纯粹是仪式。但思考这个连续体的一种方法是，如果我早上问你，你是先刷牙然后洗澡？还是先洗澡然后刷牙？疯狂的是，当我问这个问题时，实际上在世界各地的国家中，大约50%的人以一种方式做，50%的人以另一种方式做。所以他们每天早上都有这样做的事，
and they really think their way is the good way and the other way is the bad way. Now then if I ask, imagine in your head, and you can do this yourself, imagine in your head doing them in the opposite order tomorrow morning, like really simulate that you would, instead of brushing your teeth first, you'd get in the shower first. When I ask people that, a lot of people make a face, like I don't like that. That feels weird to me or that feels wrong to me. But a lot of people say, no problem at all, I'm happy to switch the order.
而且他们真的认为自己的方式是好方式，而另一种方式是坏方式。现在，如果我问，在脑海中想象一下，你也可以自己做这个，想象明天早上以相反的顺序做这些事，就像真正模拟你一样，你会先进淋浴间，而不是先刷牙。当我问人们这个问题时，很多人会做个鬼脸，好像我不喜欢那样。这对我来说感觉很奇怪或感觉不对。但很多人说，没问题，我很高兴切换顺序。
You can see in there sort of the difference between a habit and a ritual. So if you like to do things a certain way, but then if I say switch it, you don't mind. It's more like a habit. In the morning, you need to brush your teeth, need to take a shower. You have a habit of doing that. The order doesn't really matter. But if you're one of those people who felt a little weird when you thought about doing it differently, now that's a little bit further down the continuum toward a ritual because now the order in which you do things really matters to you. When it really shouldn't matter necessarily, it feels like it matters.
你可以在其中看到习惯和仪式之间的某种区别。所以如果你喜欢以某种方式做事，但如果我说切换它，你不介意。这更像是一个习惯。早上，你需要刷牙，需要洗澡。你有这样做的习惯。顺序其实并不重要。但如果你是那些在想到以不同方式做事时感到有点奇怪的人之一，那么这就更进一步接近仪式了，因为现在你做事所用的顺序对你来说真的很重要。当它其实不一定非要重要时，它感觉很重要。
And that means that it's a little bit more important to you. So rituals seem to be ubiquitous. I mean, I can't think of a culture or a time in history when humans did not engage in rituals. They can seem trivial, like buying a weekly lottery ticket, or they can be really profound, like a funeral mass. So my question is, are we physically hardwired to perform rituals? What does the science tell us about where this drive comes from? One of the interesting things about studying rituals is, of course, that many different disciplines have tackled the topic. I'm certainly not the first person to start studying rituals.
这意味着它对你来说稍微更重要一些。所以仪式似乎无处不在。我的意思是，我想不出人类不参与仪式的人类文化或历史时期。它们看起来可能微不足道，比如每周买一张彩票，或者它们可能非常深远，比如葬礼弥撒。所以我的问题是，我们在生理上是天生注定要进行仪式的吗？科学告诉我们这种驱动力来自哪里？研究仪式有趣的事情之一，当然是许多不同的学科都探讨了这个话题。我当然不是第一个开始研究仪式的人。
So if you look in anthropology and sociology, of course, in clinical psychology, which I hope we'll talk about as well, people have been looking at what rituals are and how ubiquitous they are. And in fact, if you think about how we identify that some humans had some culture way back when, we often look to see if they buried their dead in a ceremonious fashion or not. So if they don't, then we say maybe they didn't have culture in a sense. But when there's shells around the body, we use that to say they must have felt differently about death. They must have had beliefs about death. They must have wanted to honor that person as a group.
所以如果你看看人类学和社会学，当然还有临床心理学，我希望我们也会讨论，人们一直在研究仪式是什么以及它们是多么无处不在。事实上，如果你想想我们是如何识别很久以前的一些人类有某种文化的，我们经常去看看他们是否以一种隆重的方式埋葬了他们的死者。所以如果他们没有，那么我们就会说也许他们在某种意义上没有文化。但当尸体周围有贝壳时，我们用它来证明他们对死亡的感受一定有所不同。他们一定对死亡有信仰。他们一定想作为一个群体来纪念那个人。
So rituals, in a way, are one of the ways we identify when humans became human. So sheltering in place and needing to keep at least six feet away from most other people are actions that have radically altered our lives and prevented us from doing so many things. What's the long-term impact of missing out on some of the rituals I mentioned earlier, especially not being able to fully grieve loved ones we've lost to the coronavirus? I think our research would suggest that there is good news and bad news. So one of the first projects that we did on rituals I did with my colleague Francesca Gino on grieving rituals. And one of the things we saw is we sort of thought we would be studying grief in terms of the public communal rituals.
所以仪式在某种程度上是我们识别人类何时成为人类的方法之一。因此，居家隔离和需要与大多数其他人保持至少六英尺的距离是极大地改变了我们的生活并阻止我们做很多事情的行动。错过我之前提到的一些仪式的长期影响是什么，特别是无法充分哀悼我们因冠状病毒而失去的亲人？我认为我们的研究表明有好消息也有坏消息。所以我们对仪式进行的第一批研究项目之一是我与我的同事弗兰西斯卡·吉诺合作关于哀悼仪式的研究。我们看到的事情之一是我们原本以为我们会从公众公共仪式的角度来研究悲伤。
We all think of often religious rituals as well. But when we asked people, you know, think of someone who you love to have passed away. and we asked them just, what did you do after that? Many people wrote something like, there was a funeral, but then they would write something very private that they did just for that person just by themselves that often no one else even knew about. One of the examples that always stays with me
我们都经常想到宗教仪式。但当我们问人们时，你知道的，想想你爱的人已经去世了。我们只是问他们，在那之后你做了什么？许多人写了一些东西，比如，有一个葬礼，但随后他们会写一些非常私人的事情，他们只是为了那个人自己做的，通常甚至没有其他人知道。让我印象深刻的例子之一
is an older woman whose husband had passed away, and she wrote, I washed his car every week as he used to. Now, that's clearly not an established public ritual that's thousands of years old. Cars don't even exist until fairly recently. So we know that that woman made that ritual up herself. But as you listen to it, you can see how meaningful and important it was to her. And what we find in our research, and this is the good news, is that even those private ones that we make up ourselves, those are associated with less grief and better coping.
是一位老妇人，她的丈夫去世了，她写道，我像他过去一样每周洗一次他的车。现在，这显然不是一个有几千年历史的既定公共仪式。直到最近才甚至有汽车。所以我们知道那个女人自己编造了那个仪式。但当你听它时，你可以看到这对她来说是多么有意义和重要。我们在研究中发现的好消息是，即使是我们自己编造的那些私人的仪式，也与更少的悲伤和更好的应对有关。
Now, that's not to say that the communal ones aren't incredibly important because we need social support. We need all kinds of things to get through grief. And that's the bad news, that losing those really does have an impact. The good news is we can have a little bit of flexibility in creating our own, and those can help too. One of the rituals that you've studied is the simple handshake. That's something else that we can't engage in right now. Even Dr. Anthony Fauci has suggested maybe facetiously that we may never shake hands again. Do you think that's the case?
现在，这并不是说公共的并不极其重要，因为我们需要社会支持。我们需要各种各样的事情来度过悲伤。这就是坏消息，失去那些确实会产生影响。好消息是我们在创造自己的方面可以有一点灵活性，那些也能有所帮助。你研究过的仪式之一是简单的握手。那是我们现在无法参与的另一件事。甚至安东尼·福奇博士也半开玩笑地建议我们可能再也不会握手了。你认为会这样吗？
And can you talk about some of the types of communication that are inherent in handshaking, why it's so important? In research that was led by Juliana Schroger, who's at Berkeley, We tried to look to see what really handshakes are all about. In fact, I think it's apocryphal, unfortunately, but there is a story that the reason handshakes began way back when is because by shaking hands, you would dislodge any daggers from your sleeves and they would fall on the ground.
你能谈谈握手中固有的某些类型的沟通，为什么它如此重要吗？在由伯克利的朱利安娜·施罗德领导的研究中，我们试图看看握手究竟是怎么回事。事实上，不幸的是，我认为这可能是无稽之谈，但有一个故事说，很久以前开始握手的原因是因为通过握手，你会从袖子里震出任何匕首，它们会掉在地上。
So you would know you can trust the person. That's probably not true, but if you think about the psychological element there, it's really showing that you can trust me, that we can be close enough to each other to touch and nobody's going to get killed, so handshakes are a sign of trust. Now, that's exactly what we see in our research, actually, is that when people shake hands,
所以你会知道你可以信任这个人。那可能不是真的，但如果你想想那里的心理元素，它确实表明你可以信任我，我们可以彼此靠近到可以触摸并且没有人会被杀，所以握手是信任的标志。现在，这正是我们在研究中看到的，事实上，当人们握手时，
they tend to trust each other more. The reason is that by shaking hands, I'm signaling that I care about you and that you can trust me back. That's the bad news, because as you said, we can't shake hands right now, and who knows if we'll get back to that ritual. But the good news is that it's not really the handshake itself that matters. It's the ability to communicate that you care about someone else and that you trust them. And we ran a study, and this is years ago before the current crisis, where we had someone refused to shake hands with somebody else.
他们往往更信任彼此。原因是通过握手，我在发出我关心你并且你也可以信任我的信号。这是坏消息，因为正如你所说，我们现在不能握手，谁知道我们是否会回到那个仪式。但好消息是，真正重要的其实不是握手本身。而是传达你关心别人并信任他们的能力。我们做了一项研究，这是在当前危机之前的几年前，我们让一个人拒绝与另一个人握手。
And in general, people think the person's a jerk. But if the person says, hey, the reason I'm not shaking your hand is because I've had a cold. Well, now suddenly the person who shakes hands is a jerk because they're giving you a cold. And the person who doesn't, by not shaking your hand is showing they care about you and they can trust you. So again, I think we have, even though handshakes are so ubiquitous, we do have some flexibility and how we try to accomplish the goal that handshakes were doing. And again, we can be a little bit freelancing on to figure out how we can actually signal those things.
总的来说，人们认为这个人是个混蛋。但如果这个人说，嘿，我没有跟你握手的原因是因为我感冒了。好吧，现在突然间握手的人变成了混蛋，因为他们传染给你感冒。而那个没有握手的人，通过不握手表现出他们关心你并且他们可以信任你。所以再次认为，尽管握手无处不在，但在如何尝试实现握手正在做的事情的目标方面，我们确实有一些灵活性。再说一次，我们可以有点自由发挥，找出我们如何实际发出这些信号。
Quite a few athletes engage in some peculiar behaviors during or before games. For example, you noted in an article in Scientific American that Wade Boggs, the former third baseman for the Boston Red Sox, woke up exactly at the same time each day, ate chicken before each game, took precisely 117 ground balls in practice, took batting practice at 517, and ran sprints at 717. Is that kind of behavior a little crazy, or does it serve an important purpose? One of my favorite things about, I'm from Boston, Wade Boggs played for the Boston Red Sox. He also used to, when he, at every bat, he would write the Hebrew word for life in the dirt. And the best part of that is that he wasn't Jewish.
相当多的运动员在比赛期间或之前会有一些奇怪的行为。例如，你在《科学美国人》的一篇文章中指出，前波士顿红袜队三垒手韦德·博格斯每天准时醒来，每场比赛前吃鸡肉，在练习中准确接到117个地滚球，在5点17分进行击打练习，在7点17分进行冲刺。这种行为有点疯狂，还是有重要目的？我最喜欢的事情之一，我来自波士顿，韦德·博格斯为波士顿红袜队效力。他在每次击球时，还会在泥土中写下希伯来语的“生命”。最棒的部分是，他不是犹太人。
So he just decided that he would adopt something from another religion. legend that seemed to be pretty good and then bring it into his his performance. Yeah, we do see these performance rituals that are so ubiquitous. And when athletes do them, they can be incredibly elaborate. And we think they're a little unusual, but we don't, we don't really think it's a problem. So Raphael Madaal is a very elaborate preserved ritual that he does every time. And if you ask these players, why do you do it? They'll say it's a ritual and it helps me perform better. So they're doing it on purpose to try to accomplish this goal. Sometimes I think if I did one of those crazy rituals, like before I taught a class, I'd be fired because nobody thinks that teaching is as hard as playing tennis.
所以他只是决定他会采用另一个宗教传说中看起来相当不错的东西，然后把它带入他的表现中。是的，我们确实看到了这些无处不在的表现仪式。当运动员这样做时，它们可能会极其精致。我们认为它们有点不寻常，但我们并不真的认为这是一个问题。所以拉斐尔·纳达尔每次都会做一个非常精心保留的仪式。如果你问这些球员，你为什么这么做？他们会说这是一个仪式，它帮助我表现得更好。所以他们这样做是为了试图实现这个目标。有时我认为如果我做了那些疯狂的仪式之一，比如在我教课之前，我会被解雇，因为没有人认为教书和打网球一样难。
So we have context-specific rituals that we're allowed to do and not allowed to do. But even for mundane things like people like us who aren't, you know, playing professional sports, but we have to teach or lead a meeting or give a presentation that we're worried about. Alison Woodbrooks, another colleague of mine at HBS, led this project on do rituals help calm us down in those situations? And the answer is that they do, actually. So when we're feeling anxious, the worst thing to do is tell yourself to calm down. And by the way, that's the most important takeaway. Maybe the whole thing is never try to tell yourself just to calm down.
所以我们有特定情境的仪式，允许做或不允许做。但即使对于世俗的事情，比如像我们这样不从事职业体育运动的人，但我们要教书、主持会议或做我们担心的演讲。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯（Alison Woodbrooks），我在HBS的另一位同事，领导了这个项目，即仪式是否有助于我们在这些情况下平静下来？答案是，实际上它们确实有。所以当我们感到焦虑时，最糟糕的事情就是告诉自己冷静下来。顺便说一句，这是最重要的收获。也许整件事就是永远不要试图告诉自己冷静下来。
We just can't do it. But doing a little ritual before we perform actually can calm us down a little bit and then help us perform a little bit better. I've seen videos that you've done on the Internet where you have people do these rituals to demonstrate group cohesion. And so I think you have found that they do that. But on the other hand, people who are excluded from those rituals become an outgroup because they are excluded from the rituals. I mean, it's just sort of a peculiar thing that we tend to do even without thinking. And you talk about group cohesion and the importance of rituals, what they do for the people who are in the groups and how they maybe harm the people who are out. Yeah, this is one of the paradoxes of rituals is that they're not just.
我们就是做不到。但是在我们表现之前做一点小仪式，实际上可以让我们平静一点，然后帮助我们表现得更好一点。我见过你在互联网上制作的视频，你让人们做这些仪式来展示群体的凝聚力。所以我认为你已经发现它们能做到这一点。但另一方面，被排除在这些仪式之外的人会成为外群，因为他们被排除了。我的意思是，这只是一种奇怪的事情，即使不假思索，我们也倾向于这样做。你谈到了群体凝聚力和仪式的重要性，它们为群体内部的人做了什么，以及它们如何可能伤害群体外的人。是的，这是仪式的悖论之一，它们不只是。
good. And of course, we know that because rituals taken too far can become a symptom of obsessive compulsive disorder, which we know isn't good. So we know that it's not just that more rituals is better. And I would never want anyone to think that what I'm saying is more rituals is better. They have to be used when it's appropriate. But another way that they're not good for us as well is you're absolutely right. They bond us together. But in the bonding us together, they can drive us apart from other people. When I talk about this, I do have people stand up and perform a ritual in groups, and I made it up. And I just, and I say, here's something I made up. Can we all do it together? And it's things like clapping and stomping your hands and things like that. And all I say to
好的。当然，我们知道这一点，因为走得太远的仪式会成为强迫症的症状，我们知道这不好。所以我们知道，并不是仪式越多越好。我绝不希望任何人认为我的意思是仪式越多越好。它们必须在适当的时候使用。但它们对我们不好的另一个方面是，你说得绝对没错。它们把我们绑在一起。但在把我们绑在一起的过程中，它们会把我们从其他人身边推开。当我谈到这一点时，我确实让人们站起来，以小组为单位表演一个仪式，这是我编造的。我只是，我说，这是我编造的。我们能一起做吗？这些事情包括拍手、跺脚等等。我所说的只是
the group is, go ahead. And what happens is people start the ritual and they very quickly get in sync so that everyone starts clapping at the same time and then stomping at the same time. And they really like it. They feel good about each other. They're looking around smile. It's like, this is our ritual. It's great. But you also see that if someone, quote, unquote, messes up, meaning that I clap instead of stomp at the wrong time, people get very angry at the person. So they look at them, you know, what's wrong with you? And when I asked them at the end, what did you think about those people? They say, well, you know, he was doing it wrong. Now, remember, I told them I just made up this ritual that they've never done before. There's no wrong. There's no wrong. There's no right. I just made it up. I told them I just made it up. And yet immediately, that quickly we can say, this is the good way, we do it this way, and if you do it the other way, I don't like you. And we do see that in two separate projects. So with Tammy Kim, we showed that rituals can bond us together. And with Nick Thompson, we showed actually that rituals can drive us apart in exactly this way. So let's talk for a minute about rituals and clothing.
对这个小组，开始吧。发生的事情是，人们开始这个仪式，他们很快就合拍了，以至于每个人都同时开始拍手，然后同时跺脚。他们真的很喜欢它。他们对彼此感觉很好。他们环顾四周，微笑着。就像，这是我们的仪式，太棒了。但你也会看到，如果有人，也就是所谓的，搞砸了，意思是说我在错误的时间拍手而不是跺脚，人们会对这个人非常生气。所以他们看着他们，你知道，你怎么了？当我在最后问他们，你们怎么看那些人时？他们说，嗯，你知道，他做错了。现在，请记住，我告诉过他们，我只是编造了这个他们从未做过的新仪式。没有错的。没有错的。没有对的。我只是编造的。我告诉过他们我只是编造的。然而，很快，我们可以说，这是好方法，我们这样做，如果你用另一种方法，我不喜欢你。我们在两个独立的项目中确实看到了这一点。因此，通过与塔米·金（Tammy Kim）合作，我们证明了仪式可以把我们凝聚在一起。通过与尼克·汤普森（Nick Thompson）合作，我们实际上证明了仪式可以以这种确切的方式将我们推开。所以我们花一分钟来谈谈仪式与服装。
A lot of us have spent the last couple, almost two months in sweatpants or pajamas most of the day. And a popular meme on social media asks, when was the last time you wore pants? with buttons. So I think we know that clothing has meaning in pretty much every culture. What are some of the actual rituals surrounding clothing and how do they affect us psychologically? One of the very first things we did when we started studying rituals was we asked research assistants to find every grieving ritual that any human group had ever enacted in human history. So that was their task and we set them loose. And pretty much every recorded culture has a grieving ritual. It's something that often has communal elements. And we know this. Whatever culture you're in, you know exactly the one in your
我们中的许多人在过去的两周里，差不多两个月里，大部分时间都穿着运动裤或睡裤。社交媒体上的一个流行迷因问，你最后一次穿带扣子的裤子是什么时候？所以我认为我们知道，服装在几乎所有文化中都有意义。围绕服装的一些实际仪式是什么，它们如何对我们的心理产生影响？当我们开始研究仪式时，我们做的第一件事就是要求研究助理找出人类历史上任何人类群体曾经制定过的每一个悲伤仪式。所以这是他们的任务，我们让他们自由发挥。几乎所有有记录的文化都有一个悲伤的仪式。这通常具有共同的元素。我们知道这一点。无论你处于什么文化中，你都确切地知道你所处的文化中的那一个。
culture. One of the things that we found in that research is color plays an extremely important role in grieving, but it's not very consistent from culture to culture. So many, many cultures, of course, have black as the color associated with grief. You wear black to the funeral etc. Other colors, though, have white. That's the color that is associated with grief. If you wore black to that funeral, people would be furious at you. If you wore white to a funeral where black is the appropriate color, those people would be furious at you. There's other cultures where red or green are associated with grief as well. So it's really interesting to me in this way because it's clear that people want to use color to help cope with their grief and they use the color of their
我们在研究中发现的一件事是，颜色在悲伤中起着极其重要的作用，但它在不同的文化中并不是很一致。当然，很多很多的文化都有黑色作为与悲伤相关的颜色。你穿着黑色的衣服去参加葬礼等等。不过，其他颜色有白色。那是与悲伤相关的颜色。如果你穿着黑色去参加葬礼，人们会对你大发雷霆。如果你穿着白色去参加葬礼，而黑色是合适的颜色，那些人会对你大发雷霆。还有其他文化，红色或绿色也与悲伤有关。所以这对我来说非常有趣，因为很明显，人们希望用颜色来帮助应对他们的悲伤，他们使用
clothing in particular, but then there's a little bit of flexibility on exactly which color you end up using. I think the good thing about wearing colors that we've really lost is that we used to be able to signal to other people where we were in our process of grief. When people wore black for a year, for example, you would know that they'd lost someone, and that might help you support them. Now, of course, many cultures have gotten rid of those grieving rituals. So when I meet someone, I don't know if they've lost a loved one yesterday or a year before or never. So it changes my ability to support them. The plus side is, of course, now not everyone knows my business and I might be a private person.
特别是服装，然后对于你最终使用的具体颜色有一点点的灵活性。我认为穿颜色的好处是我们真正失去的，那就是我们过去能够向其他人发出信号，我们在悲伤的过程中处于什么阶段。例如，当人们穿黑色的衣服一年时，你会知道他们失去了某人，这可能会帮助你支持他们。现在，当然，许多文化已经取消了那些悲伤的仪式。所以当我遇到某人时，我不知道他们昨天失去了亲人，还是一年前，还是从未失去过。所以这改变了我支持他们的能力。当然，好处是现在不是每个人都知道我的事，我可能是一个注重隐私的人。
So there's these tradeoffs between giving up rituals to get us some things, but we also often lose some things along the way. Are there still some cultures where you have to wear a color for, say, a year? I know in my family, which was Italian, which is Italian, that you were supposed to wear black for a year if you were a widow. Is that still prevalent? Some cultures do. Actually, speaking of professional sports, you'll see sports teams often wear a black armband for a season if someone important to the sports franchise passes away. So we still see people using clothing in order to signal something important.
因此，放弃仪式以换取某些东西之间存在着这些权衡，但我们也经常在此过程中失去一些东西。是否还有一些文化，你必须穿某种颜色的衣服，比如说一年？我知道在我的家族里，它是意大利的，是意大利的，如果你是寡妇，你应该穿黑色的衣服一年。这种情况仍然普遍吗？有些文化会。事实上，说到职业体育，如果体育特许经营权中的某位重要人物去世，你会看到运动队经常在整个赛季中佩戴黑色臂章。所以我们仍然看到人们利用服装来发出重要的信号。
But the variability from culture to culture, and even within culture and subculture, is very wide in terms of exactly what people do to show that they're grieving over time. Something else a lot of us are also experiencing during our physical distancing is not being able to get our haircut or doing it ourselves or having someone we live with do the job. When does caring for our hair move from being just a habit, I get my haircut every month, or an actual ritual? We, this is a hard one for me to answer because I'm bald. I don't have a lot of these. Sadly, I don't have this problem. But even here we see, even speaking just within grief again, there we see again that people often do something with.
但从一种文化到另一种文化，甚至在文化和亚文化内部，人们为了表达随着时间的推移他们正在悲伤而做的具体事情，其变异性是非常大的。我们在保持身体距离期间也经历的很多事情是无法理发，或者自己理发，或者让与我们同住的人来做这项工作。当我们的头发护理从仅仅是一种习惯（我每个月理一次发）转变为实际的仪式时，会发生什么？我们，这个问题对我很难回答，因为我是个秃子。我没有多少这些。可悲的是，我没有这个问题。但即使在这里我们也看到，仅就悲伤而言，我们再次看到人们经常用它做些什么。
with hair when they're grieving, but it varies extremely widely again from culture to culture. So in some cultures, you shade your head when someone passes away. In other cultures, you grow your beard when someone passes away. In other cultures, you take a snippet of the person's hair and keep it like in a locket to honor them. So even within the domain of specifically hair, again, it seems like just with color, it seems like people want to do something to honor that loss. they look around for what's available. It might be clothing.
当他们在悲伤时处理头发，但它在不同的文化中再次有很大的不同。所以在某些文化中，当有人去世时，你会剃光头。在其他文化中，当有人去世时，你会留胡子。在其他文化中，你会剪下一小撮那个人的头发，把它放在像小金盒一样的东西里来纪念他们。因此，甚至在专门的头发领域，再次像颜色一样，人们似乎想做点什么来纪念这种损失。他们环顾四周看有什么可用的。可能是服装。
It might be their own bodies. And then they do something in order to try to enact a ritual to help them and to help others cope with that loss. Another obsession for some of us during the pandemic lockdown is food. We're cooking at home more. A lot of people are baking. We're starting sourdough starters, which brings to mind food rituals. And I know you've also looked at those. I'm wondering about some rituals such as.
可能是他们自己的身体。然后他们做了一些事情来试图制定一个仪式来帮助他们以及帮助他人应对这种损失。对于我们在大流行封锁期间的一些人来说，另一个痴迷是食物。我们在家里做饭更多。很多人都在烘焙。我们正在开始酸面团起子，这让人想起食物仪式。我知道你也看过这些。我想知道一些仪式，例如
as saying grace before dinner or having a sommelier go through a whole elaborate ceremony and pouring wine, does this make food somehow better for us? Bizarrely enough, it seems to. So in research led by Kathleen Voss, we actually look to see does performing rituals around food actually make the food taste better? Should it taste better? Probably not. The way you prepare something doesn't necessarily mean it will taste better. but when people prepare prepare and consume food ritualistically, we can show that they actually enjoy the experience more. Very simplest one is we gave people free chocolate. And some people we just said, go ahead and eat it. And other people we said things like first break it in half, then unwrap that half, then
在晚餐前说感恩祷告，或者让侍酒师经历一整套精心制作的仪式并倒酒，这是否能以某种方式让食物对我们更好？奇怪的是，它似乎确实如此。在凯瑟琳·沃斯（Kathleen Voss）领导的研究中，我们实际上研究了围绕食物进行仪式是否真的能让食物味道更好？它的味道应该更好吗？可能不会。你准备食物的方式并不一定意味着它的味道会更好。但是当人们以仪式化的方式准备和消费食物时，我们可以证明他们实际上更享受这种体验。最简单的一个是我们给人们免费的巧克力。有些人我们只是说，吃吧。其他人我们说了一些话，比如首先把它掰成两半，然后打开那一半的包装，然后
eat that half, then unwrote the other half, you know, not very complicated, but still an orderly progression through eating the chocolate, a little bit ritualistic. And we find that people like eating the chocolate more. in part because when you do a ritual around food, it immerses you much more in the experience. So think typically about eating food. You might be on your phone. You might be watching TV. You might be distracted.
吃那一半，然后打开另一半的包装，你知道，不是很复杂，但仍然是有序地吃巧克力，有点仪式化。我们发现人们更喜欢吃巧克力。部分原因是因为当你在食物周围做一个仪式时，它会让你更多地沉浸在体验中。所以通常想想吃东西。你可能在玩手机。你可能在看电视。你可能会分心。
You're not really engaged in the consumption act. Rituals seem to bring us into the act so that we end up savoring the food more. We're literally leaving the chocolate in our mouth longer and enjoying it more because it's sort of focused our attention on what we're doing. Are there any rituals you would recommend that our listeners engage in right now so that they can feel more in control and less stressed? In a project that we have just started since this crisis, my student Jimenez-Garcia Rada is leading this. We've surveyed parents and asked them about Jimenez-studies decision-making in couples, which is a fascinating topic in its own right. But we've looked to see what's happened to parenting during the crisis because almost everyone's parenting has changed. in very different ways, but there's been changed. So we asked people, very simple question,
你并没有真正参与消费行为。仪式似乎把我们带入了这一行为中，以至于我们最终更细细品味食物。我们实际上把巧克力在嘴里留得更久，并且更享受它，因为它某种程度上把我们的注意力集中在我们正在做的事情上。有没有什么仪式是你建议我们的听众现在就开始做的，这样他们就能感到更有掌控感，压力更小？在我们自这场危机开始以来刚刚启动的一个项目中，我的学生希梅内斯·加西亚·拉达（Jimenez-Garcia Rada）正在领导这个项目。我们调查了父母，询问了他们关于伴侣之间的希梅内斯研究决策，这本身就是一个迷人的课题。但我们一直在观察危机期间育儿发生了什么，因为几乎每个人的育儿方式都发生了变化。以非常不同的方式，但已经发生了变化。所以我们问人们一个很简单的问题，
have you created any new rituals as a parent with your kids since the crisis began? A huge number of people have, I think 50 to 60 percent say that they have. And those parents tend to feel a little better about their parenting, and they're a little bit happier with their lives in general. Now, it's obviously possible that people who are happy with their parenting have the time to create rituals. So we don't know the causal direction in this case. But it does seem as though when the world, it gives us uncertainty, we tend to look to rituals as a way to cope with the uncertainty. So parents are doing rituals around hand washing. They're doing rituals around wearing masks. They're helping their kids through the process of learning how to do that. Just like the way we do at bedtime or at meal time with
自从危机开始以来，作为父母，你有没有和你的孩子一起创造过任何新的仪式？绝大多数人都有，我认为50%到60%的人说他们有。这些父母往往对自己的育儿感觉更好一点，他们对一般的生活也更快乐一点。现在，对育儿感到满意的人有时间创造仪式，这显然是可能的。所以我们不知道这种情况下的因果方向。但看起来，当世界给我们带来不确定性时，我们倾向于将仪式视为应对不确定性的方法。所以父母正在围绕洗手做仪式。他们正在围绕戴口罩做仪式。他们正在帮助孩子们完成学习如何做到这一点的过程。就像我们在睡觉时或吃饭时做的那样
our kids where you have to have this particular bunny and then this story and then we sit over there Mommy comes in. You know, I have this whole elaborate thing for kids that we do all the time. Parents use rituals like crazy. Then for some reason we think when we're grown up, well, those are silly. We don't need them. Well, maybe if they work for kids, they might work for us, too. So we're going to be singing happy birthday as we wash our hands for the rest of our lives, right? I bet people, it's almost like an earworm. I bet people will have it way more in their head now as they're washing than they ever did before. Well, Dr. Norton, thank you so much for joining. Speaking of psychology. This has been really interesting, and I hope our listeners have learned a lot from
与我们的孩子在一起，你必须有这只特别的小兔子，然后这个故事，然后我们坐在那里妈妈进来了。你知道，我为孩子们准备了这整套精心制作的东西，我们一直在这样做。父母疯狂地使用仪式。然后由于某种原因，当我们长大了，我们认为，嗯，那些是愚蠢的。我们不需要它们。好吧，也许如果它们对孩子有用，它们对我们也有用。所以我们将在余下的生命里在洗手时唱生日快乐歌，对吧？我敢打赌人们，这几乎就像是一个洗脑神曲。我敢打赌，人们在洗手时脑子里会有更多这样的想法，比以前任何时候都多。好吧，诺顿博士（Dr. Norton），非常感谢您的加入。说到心理学。这真的很有趣，我希望我们的听众从
hearing about your research. Thank you so much. And to our listeners, thank you for tuning into our podcast. This is one of the series we have produced regarding psychology's role in helping us understand and navigate the COVID-19 pandemic. You can find other resources and tipsheets about coping through the pandemic on our website at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. All episodes are available on our website at www. www.spicingof psychology.org. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology
听到你的研究中受益匪浅。非常感谢。对于我们的听众，感谢您收听我们的播客。这是我们制作的关于心理学在帮助我们理解和应对COVID-19大流行中的作用的系列节目之一。您可以在我们的网站APA.org上找到有关应对大流行的其他资源和提示表。您还可以在Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《说到心理学》节目。所有剧集都可以在我们的网站www.spicingof psychology.org上找到。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发电子邮件至speaking of psychology
at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
发送至APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，发送至APA.org。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。